you were at my house but I wasn't there
and why wasn't I there this is a long
time ago and that was your assistant who
I met you out with another time at some
in a bar in the West in West Hollywood
but it was after some bar and and he
said oh you know come back I'm going
back to Drew's and I remember it was
like a bunch of boys went back and and
your swimming pool was so hot
it was like boiling
yeah I this is yeah this is on the track
and then also you went downstairs and
there's a little observation room you
could see people swimming yes and people
were swimming naked so yeah
well that is um a perfect parlay into
another night where we crossed pads
right
um but that particular night I was
carrying around my trusty Polaroid
camera oh no and we went to this bar and
I saw a string of Polaroids with clothes
pins strung up on string and I'm like oh
my God I took a selfie of myself with my
Polaroid camera and clipped one up on
the thing and about 10 minutes later all
of my friends were like dude no and ran
up and started pulling my picture down
and I was like why are you doing that
like whatever this is I want to be a
part of the art installation they were
like it's a contest and I was like so
and they're like it's a
fun test
it's called Big you know what night
[Applause]
I think you won I did I won
all right your new show Traders
everybody's it's buzzing people are
freaking out
if we have a clip take a look
my most esteemed guests
you're about to enter a world of
backstabbing
and treachery
and you thought the Real Housewives of
Beverly Hills was bad
but this game you will need the strength
of a lion the stealth of a fox everyone
here is capable of manipulation and
deceit do not let preconceived notions
fool or mislead you
okay in that clip we see real housewife
uh Brandi Glanville and Below decks Kate
Chastain I mean these are beloved social
media everyone's on the Feeder Frenzy
like these two women are so Infamous
what were they like in real life they're
so they know what their power is and
they have a sort of persona and then and
so to see them then in a situation where
that's being challenged like this game
was hilarious and uh Kate especially has
a really amazing sort of Journey Through
the competition an arc yes because she
gets to the point where she just wants
out you can tell she wants to go from
the game she wants and she wants to be
either because in the game you either
get murdered or banished so she was
trying to be murdered and then of course
none of the they went they refused to
murder her yeah and then the other
television yeah exactly and then the
other the other people were saying well
we're not banishing her just because she
wants to be banished so but in a funny
way that was what was the best part then
she kind of came round and became this
really good team player in Missouri and
really loved it again so it's actually a
lovely lovely sort of
little story I love that
now I heard a story about you in a
tattoo the one I think you're referring
to I don't have anyone had it removed
from my body by laser what part of your
body was it on right there I met a young
gentleman and we started a Toyota Affair
and after two weeks of knowing each
other we heard our names tattooed on
each other's bodies
uh we were we broke up four months later
and uh and so I had his I had it removed
by laser a few months later I was in LA
doing a film and I went to Cedar Sinai
and there was a great laser place but
what is a little later after that I met
up with Raven again and he said and he's
thank you
not judgments I have needs
um and he said he said he said you know
do you still have your tattoo honey I
was like No And I said do you still have
yours he went kinda and he pulled down
his pants and right there where I had
mine and instead of you see Alan and now
it says balance
[Music]